looked at me like i had done the worst
thing that i could ever do
on the face of the earth i was like and
i remember thinking myself i was like
wow he really doesn't like me this is so
weird um which is a true story that
happened off a brother
that i know subhanallah he went to a um
a car dealership yeah he went to a car
dealership with his wife
and as he was walking in he was trying
his best
yeah he's trying his best he's a human
being he's trying to sometimes he
doesn't
lower his game he's trying his best at
that moment of time he avoided looking
at the woman he realized that you know
there was a woman then he avoided her
his wife was speaking he sat down
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
their products are fantastic health
supplements and also from the sunnah
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salaam 10 for 10 of their products
assalamu alaikum brothers and sisters
and dear friends hope you guys are well
inshallah
today i wanted to do a little reaction
video to a mma fighter a female mma
fighter
um called what's her name her name is
the megan anderson so basically she's an
mma fighter she's a female
um and she had a interesting interaction
with habib the first time so we're going
to react in the first time she met habib
and khabib did something that
you know kind of got a bit angry we're
going to find out what that was we're
going to find out
why as a female she got angry about that
so much so that she actually went up to
him and
find out what she did let's watch it
together inshallah one of our guys bobby
cooper
bought the card and i was cornering him
and
he was fighting a guy that was
under habib no mega made of and uh so
habib was there cornering him
with his team and then
so normally after the fight finishes
uh the corner goes in we shake each
other's hands
we shake the fighters hands so i like i
shook i shook the opposing fighter
shook two of the coaches hands but habib
just completely ignored
me and uh
at the time at the time i feel like a
horrible person
okay guys i have to stop that cause my
dad's holding
my parents always go when i'm doing
at the time i did not know that
he was muslim so i just want to put that
out there
so i didn't know he's muslim and he just
completely ignored me so i'm like
standing there while they're announcing
the winner
i was like wow like did i do something
did i say something like
i don't think i like i didn't say
anything to him so it couldn't be i said
something like he really just doesn't
like me okay this is
this is weird interesting did i do
something wrong
does he not like me this is weird yeah
now you need to respect where she's
coming from but we're just going to
learn something very important here
she thought he doesn't like me did i do
something wrong
this is weird this is very important for
us to keep those phrases
those specific words in mind let's carry
on broken sisters
very interesting um so
they announced the announcer winner uh
his guy won our guy lost so we were
walking out the cage and we shook each
other
shook everyone's hand again i shook the
coach's hand and i went up to habib
and like i was like i'm just gonna shake
his hand like i'm just gonna go up to
him
so i went up to him i just grabbed his
hand and shook it and he looked at me
like
i had done the worst thing that i could
ever do on the face of the earth
i was like and i remember thinking
myself i was like wow he really doesn't
like me this is so weird um
okay and i walked out and then later on
someone told me that he was muslim
and that it was like a respect thing
that they didn't shake
other women's hands uh and all like
i felt like the worst person
like on earth i was like oh my god i
feel like a horrible person
um i just i just did what you don't do
and i felt so bad and i remember like
one of my friends a couple years later
went and trained at aka with uh with dc
and with her b
and he'd mentioned it to her he's like
no like i remember
um like tell her it's it is no it wasn't
a
i wasn't meant to be rude like it was a
respect thing and
like tell her not to worry about and all
that kind of stuff but like i swear
like so i'm glad that he is okay with it
but still to this day
i feel like the worst person okay now
that's very interesting our brother and
sister i just want to touch upon a few
things here
it's very important because we're living
at times where things have all changed
everything has changed everything the
opposite
yeah for example just having rulers uh
that are not fit for the position and
that's one of the signs of their
judgment the process have said that
people that are not
befitting of that you know
job are doing that liars are believed
we live at times where um subhanallah to
be chased
as a man or a woman is something wrong
you know not not to have intimacy before
marriage etc these are
no no no no and there's people out there
who go and just so they can have some
kind of
sexual experience in their life go out
and do these things men and women
you know so they don't disappoint their
husband can you imagine so or
or their wife their future wife or
husband you know so they are good in the
bedroom section
they would go and sleep with multiple
people subhanallah and it's the opposite
how it was before so whatever we look at
today brahmana says everything is hajib
like back in the days for example if you
look at the british
history in british history 100 years ago
how women were covered up
and how you look at them now and and
this goes with
muslim communities as well brothers and
sisters everything is flipped on his
head
so the things that are supposed to be
the norm have become the abnorm
yeah and we don't blame individuals but
this is a society that we're living
through and that's the reason why islam
has come to guide us and this very
interesting as a female
megan yep megan anderson as a female
she felt as if that the actions that he
did even though it was not like i i i
don't believe that megan or anybody else
that wants to shake another person's
hand
see as something as a sexual uh thing
i'm sure they don't yeah
but the thing is that the fact that she
found it weird and she started doubting
herself does he not like me
did i say something wrong and it's
actually
the opposite you it's not that he
doesn't like you
it's it's not weird in the context of to
him it's not weird
and it's because he honors you because
he believes that you are another
man's uh husband wife daughter
sister not only that even if that was
not the case
he respects you as a woman respects you
as a woman and those things brothers and
sisters
have changed so much so that you know
she she went and
grabbed his hand i'm thinking that you
know what no i'm you're not going to
disrespect me like this
so brothers and sisters it's very
important for us to understand and
acknowledge
subhanallah how these things have
changed and it shows you
the subjective worldview of people that
are going to change continuously
and if you fall into these sisters
you're just you're just going to lose
out
you know and subhanallah it's very very
sad that in today's time
females are made to be just sexual
sexually
uh sexualized objects it's like so much
so brothers and sisters
that cat calling is normal if a woman's
walking down the road
whistling at her calling her names or
trying to trip sir
this has been intrinsically
um entered into females so much so
that they think that they are worthy
or they are respected if you
can't call in the context of i'm not
saying everyone wants this i'm saying
that for example
when they you know i he likes me i'm
pretty i'm
self-worth you know increases thinking
you know what oh he's interesting he
comes and asks for my number
and so many men what they do not
understand is that
as men i'm a man i don't know i know my
psychology
you know when a man is doing that is he
really after you for the right reasons
that's the reason why we are told to
honor a woman in islam in such a way
that when you want to go and marry you
go and do it the right way allah says in
the quran tell the believing men
and the believing women to lower their
gaze why because brothers and sisters
men are visual
creatures we are visual yeah that's the
reason why you'll see sales
of magazines of women that are half
naked uh be it strip clubs
be it uh brothels prostitution these are
a booming pornography
you name it why because men are visual
that's the reason why it's important for
us to lower our gaze
because one gaze this is very important
a lot of females understand this and
they think
come on really yes really just the way
you're created in a way
where i can say wow like really does
that get to you
as a woman yes if for a man
simple one gaze can ruin a man's whole
day whole life one gaze
looking at a very attractive woman yeah
if he's a married man and it looks like
a very attractive woman there's a
lawyer's gaze etc
this can cause corruption so much so
that it can impact the heart that's why
i can't remember which scholar it was
uh but he said for example subhanallah
when allah says
quran that mankind is created weak and
obviously
it might be talking about man or female
but he was talking about specifically as
a man
he was saying how weak can you be can
you be more weak than
a man who is staring at a woman
that neither he is not getting anything
from her except
causing corruption in him his desires
and all he's doing is getting ideas in
his head
and it's causing them nothing but
problems and how weak can you be that
you're looking at something
that brings you no benefit and you and
you can't even control yourself
lowering the gaze is one of the things
that is really really hard for men
brothers and sisters
very very hard that's the reason why
it's so important for
us brothers to try our best to lower our
gaze
because allah says in the quran
indeed with hardship comes ease verily
with hardship comes ease
lowering the gaze is hard but while the
ease that will follow you in your life
is greater that is the reason why today
there are married men
who have problems in their marriage why
because they're too busy comparing their
wife to others
and when they're doing that they're not
happy and when they're not happy it
affects the family unit
do you see the ripple effect so that's
the reason why sister megan
i would like to we send this to himself
as muslims god almighty tells us to
honor woman
in a way where we should even lower our
gaze so that's the reason why even when
i'm watching this
i try my best to not look
too much you know in the context yeah
i'm trying to understand what she's
saying
you know but the thing is why because
out of respect not that there's anything
wrong with you
not that there's anything wrong with you
but it's to protect myself and if
you was to come and shake my head off
and you tried to shame khabib's and
the reason he did not want to is because
as a man look we are we doesn't mean
we're perverted yeah like oh my gosh
there might be the case that's the
reason why in today's time you have even
in
certain companies um in certain
workforces my brother sisters
they have even they're even talking
about touching a woman's knee as you're
talking to or something don't touch it
because being alone with a woman in a in
a workspace the door has to be open
these are islamic values you know why
because we're understanding psychology
of male and females
and we're seeing that this is not
working because a man and a woman cannot
just be friends
it doesn't work like that so that's the
reason why it's there to honor
my dear sister megan and when we're
looking to get married we go and do it
the right way
i'm interested in a woman yes of course
i'm going to see her and if i'm
interested i go and speak to her father
why do i speak to her father because
that's her guardian if i come and say
let's go on a date etc you don't know my
intentions
i could be a player i could have sweet
talk and say all the things that you
want to hear
for one thing and that's the reason why
you have a lot of females who are going
through so much distress
why because they've been broken again
again
and again false promises they don't even
know how to trust and love anymore
because men who have come into their
lives have done nothing
but given them false promises and broken
them so much so that when they do move
on and a genuine guy does come along
she ends up breaking him because she
doesn't know how so what self-worth
self-love and trust is that's the reason
why my dear sister megan and all females
out there watching this
islam has come to honor woman in the
right way for us to go about things
in an islamic way so that we honor you
that we don't even want to look at you
neither touch you in any way shape or
form
and that is the beauty of islam
and we hope that every single muslim man
that watches this
implements this in their life brothers
and sisters well light as a muslim man
we've got a lot of work to do
sadly you know um and i thought this was
a very interesting video
uh to just show subhanallah that
how things have changed brothers and
sisters and in today's time where we
live
that's made to be strange but we want
you guys to know inshallah
that we respect and honor every single
woman
be it our relative or not our relative
yeah relative or not our relative
and i will end on this the hadith of the
prophet peace be upon him
where a man came and he said i want to
have sexual intimacy with this woman
give me permission yeah and the
prophet's character he didn't
scold him and say hey shame on you and
the companions were there nothing what
the hell is this guy talking about
you're asking the prophet of
god to allow having a sexual intimacy
uh with a woman and the prophet
wanted you know to make him understand
and he said would you want that you know
for your sister i said no never
no one doing that to my sister what
about your mother he said no by allah
never want that for my mother and your
auntie never then why do you want to do
this to other people's sisters
and mothers and daughters and that is
where the penny dropped
let's be amongst those who honor women
brothers and sisters
and let non-muslim women and muslim
women
see how as muslim men we
honor them brothers and sisters and it
is very very important for us to do that
and i'll give you guys a story as well
which is a true story that happened of a
brother
that i know subhanallah he went to a
um a car dealership yeah he went to a
car dealership with his wife
and as he was walking in he was trying
his best
yeah he's trying his best he's a human
being he's trying to sometimes he
doesn't
lower his game he's trying his best at
that moment of time he avoided looking
at the woman he realized that you know
um there was a woman then he avoided her
his wife was speaking he sat down
and um and as she came she was you know
she recently came like um
to check the temperature you know and he
wasn't doing eye contact
and um this brother the sister came
after and he said you know what
i really really appreciate the fact that
your husband whoever he is
didn't even make eye contact with me and
it shows
and she felt so honored and she was like
it amazed me because
i've met so many muslim men that they
would just check me out
up and down et cetera try to talk to me
and this is sad this is sad that she
it it caught one of maybe one of the
reasons she uh she was having some
confidence she used to wear hijab and
she took you off etc so what does it
show your brothers and sisters it shows
you
that she felt honored and she felt you
know what there
are some and i'm not praising this
brother his brother has many faults and
trust me you know i know him he has many
faults but the thing is at this very
instance
where he said you know what i'm gonna
lower my gaze the impact that he had on
that female
so much so that the brother said that
she came to his wife
and started crying and said look you
know i used to wear the hijab
etc one little thing made such
a great impact on somebody's life and
gave islam in a better way image
brothers and sisters that's all i wanted
to say inshallah till next time assalamu
alaikum
warahmatullahi